ADULTERY A CRIME, PUNISHABLE BY
DEATH.
OUR KYUNG LAH IS OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: HE IS A SULTAN
WORTH MORE THAN $20 BILLION, THE
ABSOLUTE RULER OF BRUNEI, A
SMALL SOUTHEAST COUNTRY, BUT ONE
OF THE RICHEST NATIONS PER
CAPITA IN THE WORLD.
HE IS COURTED BY AMERICA'S MOST
POWERFUL LEADERS.
>> THIS GIVES ME A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO RENEW THE
LONG-STANDING AND WARM
FRIENDSHIP.
>> Reporter: THAT FRIENDSHIP IS
BEING STRAINED AS BRUNEI
INSTALLS A NEW ISLAMIC SHARIA
LAW THAT PUNISHES ADULTERY,
ABORTIONS, AND SAME-SEX
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FLOGGING AND
STONING.
>> NOBODY IS GOING TO SET FOOT
IN THAT DAMN HOTEL UNTIL HE IS
OUT OF IT.
>> Reporter: HE IS THE SULTAN,
AND HOLLYWOOD PROTESTERS LIKE
JAY LENO WANT THE SULTAN'S MONEY
OUT OF THE STORIED BEVERLY HILLS
HOTEL.
THE HOTEL CHAIN, CALLED THE
GEORGE CHESTER COLLECTION IS
PARTIALLY OWNED BY A BRUNEI
INVESTMENT AGENCY.
HURT THE INVESTMENT, HURT THE
SULTAN.
RICHARD BRANSON TWEETED NO
VIRGIN EMPLOY WILL STAY AT
DORCHESTER HOTELS UNTIL THE
SULTAN ABIDES BY BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS.
>> PEOPLE BEING STONED TO DEATH.
HELLO, IT'S ALL ECONOMIC.
HOW BIG AN ECONOMIC IMPACT WILL
IT HAVE?
LET'S FIND OUT AND SEE.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
>> Reporter: THE HOTEL SAYS A
BOYCOTT IS THE WRONG THING,
HURTING NOT BRUNEI, BUT THE
LOCALS.
>> IT'S GOING TO HURT OUR
EMPLOYEES.
AND THEY HAVE -- THIS IS NOTHING
TO DO WITH THEM WHATSOEVER.
>> Reporter: BUT THE BOYCOTT AND
THE CELEBRITY POWER IS BRINGING
ATTENTION TO THE SULTAN'S NEW
LAW, A LAW THAT SURPRISES
JILLIAN LAUREN, WHO SAYS SHE
KNOWS THE SULTAN LIKE FEW
OTHERS.
SHE DETAILS IN HER BOOK "SOME
GIRLS: MY LIFE IN A HAREM", THAT
AT 18 SHE WAS A MISTRESS OF THE
SULTAN'S BROTHER FOR A YEAR AND
A HALF IN BRUNEI.
ONE NIGHT LAUREN SAYS IN HER
BOOK SHE WAS GIFTED TO THE
SULTAN, WHO SHE SAYS BROKE HIS
OWN SHARIA LAW.
>> I AM A WITNESS TO THE FACT
THAT THE SULTAN WAS DRINKING,
WAS COMMITTING ADULTERY, WAS,
YOU KNOW, NOT EXACTLY LIVING ON
THE STRAIGHT AND NARROW.
>> FOR THEM TO THEN PASS THIS
HARSH LAW.
>> RIGHT.
>> HOW DO YOU VIEW THIS?
>> IT'S MAYBE INDICATIVE OF THE
WAY THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
POWER BEHAVE, WHICH IS IT'S ONE
RULE FOR THEM AND ANOTHER RULE
FOR THE REST OF THE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE SO MUCH MONEY AND
DON'T HAVE SO MUCH POWER.